for sure I think it's crazy too because
just from like a Fan's perspective being
like such a big fan of you early and
chance really early like to see you guys
reconcile after all those years where I
just feel like they were like years lost
yeah
like Peak like greatness you know what
I'm saying and and it was it's just dope
to see you guys you do an internet tape
he's doing acid rap
um you know I think you guys are both so
important to Chicago and to a lot of
these kids in the last like decades so
for you was it like uh for you guys to
kind of put whatever issues you had
behind you and move forward with
positivity and you know I mean kind of
pick up where you guys left off because
you guys kind of came into this [__]
like literally we definitely did before
this [__] even you know what I mean like
age 14. you know what I'm saying
before
rap was anything more than a dream um
and I think like
when he came to visit me in Ghana
and you know we started to build this
festival and really just that moment in
Africa like that return I think that
really just helped to solidify cement
our relationship our friendship as men
you know I mean like the things that we
went through ups and downs as boys you
know I mean like just
that happens Brothers fight right you
know what I'm saying and
don't let you get rich and famous and be
super young you know what I mean like
that's that could be a recipe for
disaster and and to be fair both of you
guys had kind of like meteoric quick
rises in terms of like from being like
kind of like mixtape underground blog
Darlings to being like
what the [__] like you're you're a
Rockefeller or you're with Roc Nation
and he's you know I mean Acid Rap just
kind of changed things yeah that's yeah
it just got crazy she got crazy quick
with both your guys yeah it got crazy
real quick you know what I'm saying and
um I really can't stress enough though
like
how much of a blessing it is to be able
to learn from those things yeah and grow
from a man like that's something I speak
about a lot in this album it was like
two years ago I believe uh juice world
day and
um I was in the studio with Bongo Bongo
by the way he's the executive producer
of this album and we're in LA but I'm
looking at social media things of juice
world day and
I was just overtaken by a sense of
gratitude because I'm looking and I'm
considering the factors that led into
that situation and just realizing that a
lot of young artists don't get the
chance to evolve to evolve and learn you
know what I mean like and we're all
oftentimes so caught up in the
romanticized in the drugs and the you
know yeah like we never got to see the
juice world has like a real like he
didn't even have chance to mature and be
like we like he was a kid like people
forget like he's like actually really
what happens with so many artists though
you know what I'm saying it's like like
even X like we didn't see X have that
you know because I feel like he was
moving a lot of positivity before he
died you know and I was like damn we
didn't even get to really see his like
Legacy play out like him really growing
up and and like you know what I mean
like you know it's really a blessing
it's just a blessing like I I can't
overstate that because a lot of young
artists don't get that chance to like
stumble fall and get up and learn from
it you know what I'm saying and it's
almost like being a hip-hop artist is
like
an endangered species sometimes like
being a young rapper yeah you know
already being a young black man is a
Target on your back being a young rapper
is magnified tenfold and
um you know all I could all I could
really do is
really try to express the lessons that
I've learned through all of the
tumultuous time and you were literally
thrown in the in the in the world right
in the mix you know
um but it's a big blessing though you
know I mean even starting this album
like
beginning this album
um is when I really turned things around
mentally you know I mean like
cut out all the drinking all the drugs
everything like went sober just got
focused laser focused to a point where I
feel like I've been clearing my spirit
out and transforming my energy so I
really feel I feel Limitless I feel like
I've been
gifted to achieve magnanimous things at
a very young age and now I'm gifted once
again to
take it further you know what I mean
take it further with intention and
um from
from a place of clarity and focus
yeah I mean I think I think um you can
like have you ever reached out to any of
these young artists and just like
hey I see what you're doing like you
know or maybe try to give them some
advice because you've like you said
you've kind of been
you've you've had to live through what
it's like to be like
thrown in the middle of this
machine that is the music industry it'll
eat Chip it'll spit you out and it'll
you know it'll stop answering your calls
you know what I'm saying like if you see
somebody making mistakes whether there's
somebody close to you or like you reach
out do you try to give them any advice
or is it really not your place you feel
like you know I think I just try to
lead by example and
let my actions
speak for me at this point in time you
know and
if I can Inspire or influence somebody
with something I say on a podcast with
bootleg cash or something I say on a
record or just something that they see
me do you know Vic Mensa does this for
the homeless in Chicago or you know XYZ
uh freeze somebody from prison I'm like
man let me let me let my actions you
know speak for themselves because in the
midst of in the midst of so many things
that we've discussed
um is also like uh
just this mountain of positive impacts
of left on the planet which was has
always been the conflicting thing that I
had to realize like
you can't have it both ways like you
can't have it constantly in beef and
drama and getting locked up for this and
still be giving away a million point
five dollars worth of shoes in the
trenches in Chicago sleeping underneath
the viaduct in the dead of winter to
raise money for the homeless building
water facilities in Africa I mean like I
let those things speak for themselves
but it's not a lot of people in the
history of hip-hop that have
at this stage like had the level of
impact on people in a humanitarian sense
and that I have also that's not the [__]
that for whatever reason will get that's
not viral it's not going viral bro but
that's human nature though it's like
sit and turn on the news right now you
know what I mean like there's nothing
positive on there's nothing about any
channel you turn in because bad news
travels fast three people shot here two
people overdosed on fentanyl uh you know
Ukraine is being bombed because bad news
travels fast and we're in a culture in a
moment in society that
prioritizes
sensationalism because it's all about
the internet you know and it's all about
Impressions engagement
likes comments and you get a lot more
likes and comments on arguments
controversies and thing and fear than
you do on like love and that's kind of
like our whole news consumption cycle is
like it's just fear-driven like just
like what do we got what are we going to
be scared about today you know what I'm
saying for real it's all fear-mongering
like I think covid showed us that more
than anything because like we were all
just like watching like at home just
watching CNN and they would just have
like the death numbers just there's like
a ticker at the bottom like it was an
NBA score or something I don't think we
really realize like damn like that like
like that was a really I was like
[__] freaked out to go outside you
know what I'm saying like and you know
a lot of us got it and survived a lot of
us passed away
man I had covered like twice at least I
might have had it twice too I had
covered before we even knew what cover
was I know I had a lot of homies who
were like right around December January
December
I was in bed for like days I just it was
like a fever dream I just remember like
rolling around in bed for days you know
didn't even get up I didn't eat yeah no
for sure